oh hey Ana have you seen Heather around
yeah actually I just got finished taking
care of her you took care of her yeah I
mean she didn't give me much of a choice
did you know she's barely seen any of
the Simpsons so you got rid of her
Walter we can handle an episode without
Heather I mean you've seen The Simpsons
right yes
oh good The Simpsons is an animated show
that has been on the air for 30 seasons
it follows the American family The
Simpsons and the other residents of
Springfield starting in its second
season there have been annual Halloween
specials comprised of three short
stories they're a way for the writers to
play around with their characters
without having to answer to the show's
continuity these specials are known as
the tree houses of horror
these are the top five best treehouse of
horror episodes number 5 treehouse of
horror 13 fright to creep and scare
harms after Lisa successfully convinces
the citizens of Springfield to
relinquish their firearms some undead
villains take advantage of the recently
defenseless town the zombie Cowboys
rained terror upon the poor residents
and someone has to travel back in time
to fix their mistakes this is not the
first or even best zombie episode of The
Simpsons and leaves you with mixed
messages but the other stories in the
special were memorable enough to curve
its grade
island of dr. Hibbert the island of dr.
Moreau may seem like a heavy subject for
a family cartoon and it is this was a
properly disturbing retelling while the
Simpson family vacations in a mysterious
island some creepy animal hybrids start
popping up dr. Hibbert will not be
stopped and continues his unforgivable
experiments on the Simpson family this
segment sure stayed memorable thanks to
its disturbing visuals and although it's
dark for a regular episode it feels
right at home in a Halloween special
send in the clones in this parody of
multiplicity Homer buys a magic hammock
that duplicates himself for a while
having multiple homers is a benefit to
his loved ones and himself by taking his
less desirable duties eventually he
creates too many versions of himself to
control them and decides to abandon the
duplicates in a field with the hammock
of course the clones use this hammock to
replicate themselves to an absurd amount
they then devour entire farms with the
food and factories worth of beer a fun
hypothetical tale on why the world can
only handle one Omer at a time number
four tree house of horror
15 for beheadings and a funeral in this
Sherlockian episode The Simpsons
utilizes dark humour to tackle another
whodunit seeing The Simpsons characters
in other time periods is a clever way to
play with classic tropes it's hard for
any episode to live up to who shot mr.
burns but this story still has a couple
twists to keep you on your toes
Ned's own after an accident Ned Flanders
gains the ability to predict people's
deaths this distressing new power comes
at a cost he sees himself killing Homer
Simpson when Flanders tries to prevent
himself from committing this act he
realizes he must kill Homer to stop the
end of the world this episode features
this dying bit that still makes me
giggle to this day
[Music]
oh you stupid son of a-- belly of the
boss at a science convention maggie
climbs into a pill just before it
shrinks and is consumed by mr burns
after being shrunken themselves the
remaining simpson's go into his body to
retrieve the baby once inside the family
must locate the stomach before the
stomach acids dissolve her with maggie
on board they don't have enough power to
bring everyone back so one person must
stay behind this is when homer chooses
to stay behind and expands inside of mr.
burns starring me for life thankfully I
was immediately cured when they danced
to the most fitting song I've got you
under my skin a rollercoaster of an
episode with an unforgettable conclusion
number three treehouse of horror 7 the
genesis tub during a science experiment
with soda
Lisa accidentally creates life her tiny
tooth town evolves quickly but is
partially destroyed by Bart's
carelessness the civilization shrinks
Lisa to worship her as their God and
recruit her help
for revenge this tale is the weaker part
of this episode but I really enjoyed the
different animated angles citizen King
when Homer is abducted aliens Kang and
kodos demand to be taken to the leader
of Earth because Homer is American and
an American election is imminent they
have to get creative with taking over
the humans naturally they take over Bob
Dole and Bill Clinton's forms so that no
matter the outcome an alien will rule
their new forms are incredibly
suspicious but no one believes homers
wild claims until it is too late this
has some great political commentary
including this satirical gem we must
move forward not backward upward not
forward and always twirling twirling
twirling towards freedom
[Applause]
the thing and I when a mysterious noise
comes from the Attic the Simpson
children investigate letting loose
whatever was chained up there that
whatever was actually a hidden sibling
that looks like Bart they discover Hugo
was once Bart's conjoined twin but was
believed to be pure evil so they were
separated Hugo has been hell-bent on
returning to Bart side but when dr.
Hibbert realizes Bart is the real evil
twin the boys switch lives to have it
the way it always should have been this
is the best example of how these
Halloween specials can mess with
continuity in the best way
number two the treehouse of horror for
the devil and Homer
I have desperation and hunger Homer
sells his soul for a donut he out what's
the devil by not finishing his donut but
for obvious reasons that is short-lived
when he does consume the final bite he
is held in hell until the trial for his
soul the best part of this episode is
Homer being tortured by feeding him
donuts eternally if you know Homer
that's not even close to a bad thing the
most memorable details of this segment
are the cannibalistic donut Homer and
devil Flanders himself terror at five
and a half feet in this Twilight Zone
parody Bart discovers a monster on the
side of the bus unfortunately no one
else sees it or believes him after Bart
is able to fight the creature away
everyone realizes he was actually
telling the truth for once when he is
carted away in an ambulance however the
gremlin is far from taking care of this
segment is so true to the characters it
feels like it could have absolutely been
a regular episode if it weren't for that
whole ending thing Bart Simpson's
Dracula the Simpson family is invited to
mr. burns for a midni dinner which in no
way is suspicious Lisa stop being so
suspicious did everyone watch their
necks like mr. burns ass
Lisa and Bart go snooping around the
castle and discover a basement full of
coffins they find ample evidence that
mr. burns is a vampire but no one does
anything until bart is turned into a
vampire to stop the vampirism from
spreading
they must kill the head vampire Homer's
boss mr. burns this final story is full
of hilarious one-liners and works
perfect as the cap on a standout special
with plenty of quality stories to choose
from we had to get picky to keep this
list to only 5 while some stories shined
together
others were muddled by their companions
and barely missed our countdown
[Music]
and the number one best treehouse of
horror episode is treehouse of horror 5
the shinning the Simpson family takes
over a lodge for the winter when mr.
burns takes away all the beer and cable
Homer quickly descends into a homicidal
rage hilariously the warm glow of
television cures everything
this classic parody still holds up and
it's a great Cliff Notes version of the
original movie The Shining Shh you want
to get sued time and punishment in one
day Homer fixes the family toaster a
little too well turning it into a time
machine he knows not to alter anything
in the past or else it will have dire
consequences in the future of course
Homer can't help himself he irreparably
changes the future to a world where Ned
Flanders is master of the world and
anyone who questions his leadership must
be lobotomised
so Homer must continuously travel back
in time to undo his original mistake
it's delightful to watch all the
different timelines Homer creates and
his inevitable miscalculations nightmare
cafeteria at the Springfield Elementary
School food is scarce and misbehaving
children are plentiful Principal Skinner
realizes that each problem is the other
solution a student start to disappear
Lisa and Bart go looking for answers
only to find the worst the faculty have
been caging and eating the students this
episode is one of the darkest and has
three solid parts that all hold their
weight
hence the coveted top spot it even wraps
up with a musical number
featuring the Simpson family turned
inside out perfectly creepy right
by the way Walter do you have a favorite
Simpsons character ah
Burt no Leela Leela is my favorite you
haven't watched The Simpsons
no but please don't kill me like you
killed Heather killed Heather no no no
no I took care of Heather she's had a
busy weekend at twitchcon currently she
is doing gonna be on the couch
watching so Simpsons but you had blood
on your hands oh yeah that's because I
found out Tamra's never seen Sharkboy
and Lavagirl we want to hear what you
guys think what's your favorite
Treehouse of Horror episode what do you
want us to cover next in the show leave
a comment and let us know you can like
my Facebook page or follow along on
Twitter you can find me on Facebook
Twitter Instagram or subscribe to my
animated movie review series right here
on YouTube well catch you back here next
week with a brand new episode of top 5
thank you for watching October top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]